[Musique]
au sel fabien 52 ans candidat du parti
communiste l'élection présidentielle
c'est votre première campagne bonjour et
bienvenue fabien roussel bonjour nous
allons voyager avec vous dans les
archives de l'ina pour tenter de révéler
votre adn en commençant par vos racines
votre prénom fabien est un indice pour
savoir d'où vous venez vos parents vous
ont appelé ainsi en hommage aux au
colonel fabien militants communistes
résistant auteur du premier attentat
contre un soldat allemand au métro
barbès en outre 41 morts à la guerre
trois ans plus tard voici l'hommage des
actualités filmées de l'époque
va bien avait 26 ans sa femme
aujourd'hui déporté en allemagne son
père fusillé par les allemands formait
avec lui dans ce faubourg de paris 1
foyers d'ouvriers parmi d'autres foyers
ouvriers boulangers il ne savait rien de
romain rolland mais il respire l air ou
en hurlant ajouté tant de fois c'est
pour cela peut être qu'il fut à 17 ans
un soldat en espagne
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'on métro
barbès il a bâti le premier allemand tué
à paris
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il crée en
france les premiers maquis de la liberté
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il fut jeté
dans un cachot doubs par un souterrain
il s'évada bijoux après
c'est pour cela peut-être qu'il a pris
sa part dans la libération de paris en
faisant flotter les procureurs sur le
luxembourg
non ni colonel c'est pour cela peut-être
qu'il partait pour le front de lloret n
est que dans un coup de main il il est
mort
vous est il programmé pour devenir
militant es communistes maintenant on
n'est pas des machines on est des
humains d'abord mais c'est vrai que mes
parents m'ont donné ce nom en hommage au
colonel fabien qui était son nom de
résistant mais qui s'appelait pierre
georges et j'ai vu une photo où on voit
avec son bébé dans les bras c'est
monique puisque j'ai rencontré sa fille
un hommage à la commune j'étais assez
ému mais voilà chacun beaucoup ont
parfois des prénoms qui sont
qui font référence à l'histoire à des
personnalités du monde des arts de la
culture moi c'est un résistant et donc
j'ai jeu j'en suis plutôt fier aux
paysages d'enfance vous en parlait
souvent vous êtes un gars du nord comme
vous dites êtes né à béthune dans un
hors pas-de-calais qui me va pas bien
dans une région qui voit fermer ses
mines et ses usines
1968 un an avant votre naissance extrait
d'un reportage de cinq colonnes à la une
dans le nord ça va mal la surprise c'est
que ça va plus mal crayon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1967 le chômage a doublé régime n'ont
pas de calais cinquante mille
travailleurs chiffres officiels le nord
et sept pour cent des travailleurs de
france et 12 % des chômeurs de france
c'est une surprise comme en or cette
région pilote cette espèce de roue en 16
at il pu en arriver là et bien
simplement parce que les trois
industries base qui ont fait la richesse
de cette région charbon de textile la
sidérurgie en font maintenant sinon la
pauvreté du moins apporte la menace une
décadence progressive et innovant 36 ans
de faux alors comment ça se passe
maintenant par acheteur me suis sorti de
leur dire ça votre mais j'ai macho il
vient de partir à l'armée
quand il m'a rappelé qu'il va retrouver
n'y a rien de prévu pour les causes et
quiches et qui est responsable de tout
chaud chez biotherm men est fausse mais
on aurait dû prévenir du boulot pour les
jeunes on ne revient implanter des
usines tout partout qu'est ce qu'on va
faire je n'ai cora que ces gens vivent à
l'école quand tu quand tu es jolie voir
l'ag de travailler il n'y a rien pour
lui je m'intéresse à ça
comme ça ils saboter tout est votre site
est d'accord pour un ami lui mâcher
remet à un les mineurs et perd avis
tout le monde il ya passé d'al famille
mais aujourd'hui on arrive à un point ya
rien y'a plus rien qu'est-ce qu'il vous
inspire ce mineur qui s'inquiète pour
son fils c'est tellement sincère quand
il parle et c'est tellement encore comme
ça aujourd'hui il n'ya plus les mines
heureusement
bah oui personne ne peut regretter les
mines de charbon fabien roussel non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous avez
mineurs ils étaient fiers de leur
travail c'était dur il y laisser la vie
mais ils étaient fiers fiers de leur
travail de vivre de leur travail et y
compris fier d'avoir chauffer toute la
france au lendemain de la guerre
souvenez vous que les français se
souviennent que les mineurs en 45 46 on
travaillait gratuitement les dimanches
les jours de congés pour pouvoir
chauffer les hôpitaux les écoles
parisiennes notamment parce que c'était
le lendemain au lendemain de la guerre
il y avait plus rien ils l'ont fait ils
étaient fiers de cette histoire là et
pourtant avec l'ouverture du marché
européen
notamment la ceca et compagnie la
sidérurgie à fermer les mines ont fermé
sans prévoir d'industrie nouvelles comme
on l'a vu sur une des pancartes
aujourd'hui on vit la même chose quand
une usine de bridgestone à béthune
c'est le bassin minier ferme comme on
l'a vu il ya quelques mois pour 800
hommes et femmes qui travaillent là
dedans c'est la fin de la vie c'est pour
eux le travail c'est la vie il faut
comprendre ça le travail c'est la vie et
quand on prive les gens de leur travail
on les tue c'est dramatique et c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait de ce combat pour
l'industrie pour l'emploi le le coeur de
mon combat parce que ça me touche j'ai
pour moi c'est l'humanité elle est là
cet homme c'est le genre humain pourquoi
le parti communiste at il perdu ses
bastions éprouvé par la crise on n'a pas
perdu d'abord ya pas de bastions il y en
a j'aime pas ce terme il n'y a pas deux
bastions parce que c'est les gens qui
nous élisent sa tombe pas du ciel et
donc les maires qui était
lé maire communiste de ces villes
c'était des anciens mineurs c'était des
anciens sidérurgistes
ils travaillaient parfois à la fosse et
les habitants les faisait élire maire
quand il se présentait parce qu'ils
avaient besoin de quelqu'un qui la
représente bien qu'ils les défendent et
donc c'était ça qui faisait notre force
et quand on tue le travail quand on
ferme les usines ah bah oui c'est plus
dur pour un parti comme nous qui
représente justement le travail et les
usines mais nous avons montré lors des
dernières élections départementales
notamment que nous pouvions regagné
regagné en défendant le monde du travail
regagné justement en présentant des élus
issus du monde du travail et c'est ce
que nous avons fait dans le bassin
minier vous choisissez d'abord le
journalisme comme votre père coursier
l'humanité puis reporter d'image nous
avons retrouvé l'un de vos sujets pour
france 3 champagne ardenne oulala pour
commencer je vous propose de découvrir
les lieux d'aller à la rencontre de ses
habitants de découvrir les spécialités
sachets même que le sel à sa capitale
c'est à marcel en moselle tout de suite
premier reportage lorsque ce dernier
fabien roussel sur la route du sel
lâchement soulière
c'est vous qui filme et son commentaire
vous auriez pu rester journaliste non
non je filme et pas j'étais journaliste
à l'époque et pas seulement à la caméra
moi j'étais prêt j'ai commencé à la
caméra est là pour france 3 lorraine
champagne ardenne nous partions en
équipe où il y avait un journaliste un
opérateur 1 et claireaux un ingé son as
oui elle était belle la télévision
publique quand on lui donner les moyens
de faire des reportages comme ça il ya
de la qualité petit clin d'oeil quand
même pour les moyens pour la télévision
publique mais c'était c'est j'ai
découvert une superbe région et j'ai
travaillé aussi joué à roland leroy j'ai
travaillé à l'humanité ou là j'ai fait
tous les étages de ce journal j'ai été
coursier j'ai été je découpais les
dépêches pour les donner aux
journalistes c'est là où j'ai découvert
un petit peu le métier et j'étais au
coeur de l'actualité c'était passionnant
j'ai travaillé aussi à l'iconographie au
service photo on avait un service photo
avec des des photographes qui qui
participait à la vie du journal quoi et
qui avaient leur propre leur propre
travail et donc vous auriez pu rester
journaliste bien sûr a bien sûr je
trouve ce métier passionnant je le
respecte profondément et
j'aurais pu le rester après la vie a
fait que ont bifurqué c'est difficile
d'y revenir c'est difficile d'y revenir
quand on s'est engagés politiquement ce
que je comprends alors voyons vos
premiers pas en politique votre big bang
[Musique]
avec le communisme en héritage enfants
votre père vous a même distribué des
tracts à la sortie des usines à 16 ans
vous prenez votre carte aux jeunesses
communistes et on vous retrouve même si
vous n'êtes pas à l'image dans un coup
de force contre une célèbre épicerie de
luxe à paris aux jets d eau vous y étiez
oui aux cris de les fauchés chez fauchon
[Musique]
plus d'une centaine de jeunes chômeurs
et des membres des jeunesses communistes
ont occupé samedi en début d'après-midi
la célèbre épicerie de luxe fauchon
place de la madeleine
après s'être servis dans le magasin les
jeunes ont présenté une vendeuse des
bons d'achat d'actifs j'étais dans
l'image
j'ai occupé ces magasins où on peut
trouver des bouteilles de digestif
1200000 la pièce il y a dans ce pays les
gens qui n'ont rien absolument rien pour
vivre pour passer fed et d'autres qui
ont motivé au poids grandissant des deux
un luxe insolent les manifestants ont
été délogés par la police violemment
selon as we violemment on a pris des
coups de matraque des magasins tout
rentrait dans l'ordre il m'a semblé
reconnaître jacques perreux le leader
des communistes de l'époque et et vous
même âge l'âge vous allez je crois je
suis avec mes copains on était ensemble
et je les ai je les ai reconnus donc
devait être derrière avec eux mais je
m'en souviens parfaitement ont dénoncé
effectivement cette société à deux
vitesses et je me demande si c'est pas
moi qui tourne le dos je vois qu'ils
olivier marché avec qui je suis là qui
est la première
et on est toujours ensemble d'ailleurs
et donc quand on a ont dénoncé donc
ses magasins pour les riches et en même
temps une société du chômage qui était
en train de grandir et c'était
insupportable ont dénoncé les emprunts
giscard qui avaient été mises en place
ou en gros en plus quand on était riche
on pouvait emprunter avec des intérêts
derrière qui nous faisait gagner de
l'argent on a été
évacuée manu militari par les crs on a
pris des coups sur la tête et à la
sortie de ce magasin j'ai été embarqué
je me suis retrouvé dans un commissariat
où j'ai été mis nu pour
certainement pour m'humilier ils m'ont
fait mettre à poil voilà ils m'ont
laissé à poil comme ça pendant un long
moment
pour puis après ils m'ont demandé de me
rhabiller et puis dans la nuit j'ai été
j'ai été libéré
je vois là je m'en souviens ça m'a
marqué mais à quoi ça sert ce genre
d'action ça permet de sa paire mais
c'est comme ça ça permet d'avoir
les caméras qui se tournent vers ces
insupportables inégalités qui existent
dans le pays
il faut parfois faire deux autres des
opérations de ce type pour montrer
regarder pendant que la mise est
agrandie d'un côté il y à des familles
qui continuent de s'enrichir et qui ont
même leurs magasins propres à propre à
eux dans lequel un pauvre il va pas
rentrer puisque c'est inaccessible c'est
même pas à sa bourse ça existe encore
aujourd'hui ces inégalités noms n'ont
fait que croître ces dernières années là
en pleine pandémie en plus et donc ce
sont ces inégalités qui nourrissent
quotidiennement mon combat vous êtes
élue députée en 2017 et l'année d'après
surprise vous êtes désigné à la tête de
votre parti à 49 ans vous succéder à
pierre laurent un nouveau nom s'affiche
à la tête du parti communiste fabien
roussel vient d'être élue sans surprise
secrétaire national du parti
dans l'assistance le père de fabien
roussel militant communiste et ancien
journaliste à l'humanité il va là où
s'offre le plus donc sur le lieu de
travail dans les quartiers déshérités
c'est ce qui fait pour moi un homme un
vrai communisme donc pour moi c'est un
grand jour mon fils entrent dans
l'histoire soizic fait partie des 736
délégués régionaux venus voter ce
dimanche pour eux fabien roussel incarne
un nouveau souffle
beaucoup de personnes du nord sont comme
ça mais son côté cash on enlève rien au
fond politique qui la mène et aux
batailles qui mène notamment sur
l'évasion fiscale dont il a pris la
suite en pédalant de l'enjeu pour fabien
roussel et de renouer avec les classes
populaires le pc a réalisé moins de 3% à
l'élection présidentielle le monde
ouvrier il s'en parlait il le connaît et
c'est le retour du monde ouvrier dans le
parti communiste français le parti de
l'international va devoir repartir à la
conquête des territoires
vous avez vous lu ce post fabien roussel
vous avait intrigué pour cela non pas du
tout pas du tout ça nous est tombé
dessus comme ça quand j'avais déjà au
sort non mais j'ai quand je dis nous
c'est parce que c'est vrai qu'un jour ma
femme me dit 10 dont j'ai entendu parler
que ont parlé de toi comme secrétaire
national alors on était le congrès avait
lieu jeudi à y en a qui disent ça mais
c'est improbable je vois pas pourquoi je
deviendrai sq international donc je
démens pas comme ça mais parce que bon
mais ça va pas arriver et c'est arrivé
trois mois après et donc je faisais
partie de ceux qui voulaient que ça
change
qu'on soit beaucoup plus sur les
questions sociales sur les questions
liées à l'emploi l'industrie à la
défense du monde ouvrier j'étais de
ceux-là qui voulaient que ça change
parce que c'est notre pays vraiment
s'appauvrissent et parlent parlent à la
perte de du travail du sens que l'on
doit donner au travail et donc je
voulais que ça change et puis bah voilà
au bout d'un moment oui c'est pas que
mon nom est sorti du chapeau mais il a
été celui qui a été le plus soutenu le
plus porté puis quand on vient vous voir
et qu'on vous dit tout va bien voilà
c'est toi qui fais la majorité donc tu
dois y aller qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise moi je moi je vous je
voulais on ne peut pas à ce moment là se
soustraire à ses responsabilités et puis
pigé j'ai souhaité j'ai accepté et j'ai
voulu le faire avec pierre laurent dans
un esprit de rassemblement
parce que le parti communiste a failli
exploser à ce moment-là et on a tout
fait pour que ça n'explose pas parce que
la fraternité continue toujours à nous
rassembler mais et donc voilà et puis et
puis et puis c'est tout
allons à présent chercher vos mentors
parmi les figures qui vous ont forcément
marc hélias l incontournable de georges
marchais leader du pc pendant plus de
vingt ans vous avez écrit que vous
admiriez à la fois comme politique et
aussi parce que vous l'avez dit son fils
olivier et l'un de vos amis proches on a
donc choisi une image familiale image
rare de georges marchais avec sa femme
liliane et son fils olivier en vacances
dans leur maison de mougins en 75
avec la ds
appuyé
avec les chemises avec l'école
de l'époque
et avec kilian
instant familiale images muettes chez
les marchés avec le fils olivier que
vous avez retrouvé au lycée vous appeler
mon poteau qui est à vos côtés pour
votre campagne ami d'enfance fils de
camarades qu'est ce qui vous lie je me
suis retrouvé
dans ce lycée louise michel à champigny
sur marne après que mais mes parents se
soient séparés ma mère a quitté le pas
de calais on est venu s'installer là
dans le val de marne j'étais adolescent
et
et puis au lycée je sympathise avec des
amis une bande d'amis et parmi eux
olivier le choix la bleuse pas je crois
la première fois qu'on se rend compte
moi je sais pas c'est le fils de georges
je suis même pas militant à l'époque et
on n'est pas engagé politiquement et
puis on se lie d'amitié ce qui est fort
c'est que la bande de potes que nous
étions à l'époque au lycée nous sommes
toujours aujourd'hui et c'est quelque
chose qu'on a en commun
olives et les autres c'est que la
fidélité en amitié c'est énorme c'est ça
ça construit une vie nos enfants ont
grandi ensemble
à toute cette bande on continue de
retrouver les moyens de partir en
vacances ensemble dès que c'est possible
s'est il n'y a rien de plus beau que
l'amitié est que la fidélité en amitié
parce qu'on sait que quoi qu'il arrive
on se soutient on est on est unis on est
une famille mais c'est aussi une
fidélité au parti communiste
fabien roussel mais je pense vous avez
des à la droite je joue oui bien sûr oui
mais c'est pas une question de parti
parce que parmi la bande d'amis amis y
ait eu parce qu'il ya aussi des copines
des amis et femmes parmi la bande et on
on parle de politique mais
je ne saurais pas vous dire où j'ai
peut-être des idées de ce que chacun
peut mettre dans l'urne au moment du
vote j'espère qu'ils voteront pour moi
s'il vous plaît votez pour moi au moins
un premier tour s'il ya un doute vous
pouvez poser des questions je me permets
pas leur faire passer un message mais
aux élections municipales cantonales
régionales législatives comme on est un
petit peu disséminés en france chacun
vote en fonction de ses convictions
c'est pas la politique qui nous unit on
a des valeurs on a des valeurs fortes
entre nous on a une histoire commune
il ya personnes d'extrême droite chez
nous personne d'extrême droite le
racisme l'antisémitisme
tout ça c'est banni l'homophobie c'est
pas chez nous
mais on a des valeurs qui nous unissent
et c'est ça qui est plus fort que tout
et georges marchais il a été joueur je
marchais et leur paternel mais ça c'est
ça me concerne et georges marchais il a
il est pour moi un homme
politique un grand homme politique pour
lequel d'ailleurs les français ont
encore beaucoup d'affection fort en
gueule mais proche des gens qui
parlaient comme eux et est donc c'est ce
que j'aime chez lui dans une période qui
était pas simple quand même un avec
l'affrontement entre les blocs c'était
compliqué mais
je sais aussi que l'époque dans laquelle
il a été dirigé le parti où elle était
députée n'est plus la même époque
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait plus le même
monde et donc si on est toujours le
parti du monde du travail du monde
ouvrier le monde économique a changé et
aujourd'hui nous devons construire un
parti communiste français et une gauche
adapté aux enjeux économiques de notre
époque l'autre figure qui vous a inspiré
celle de vos tout premier combat c'est
celle de nelson mandela ah oui alors lui
libérer en 90 après 27 ans de prison en
afrique déchets
nelson mandela tenant sa famille
ses premiers pas d'homme libre premiers
pas hésitants comme surpris de la foule
est venue attendre
la dernière barrière franchie ses
parents sa prison du monde extérieur
15h15 à paris
l'instant historique qu'il est fin 27
ans 6 mois et 6 jours d'activités pour
cet homme de 71 ans
c'est merveilleux j'en ai des frissons
encore
et un vrai bain de foule du symbole
vivant de la lutte anti-apartheid sans
aucune déclaration le couple mandela
prend aussitôt la route précédé d'un
immense cortège
direction l'hôtel de ville du cap parce
que son kilomètre des dizaines de
milliers de personnes sont déjà massés
là attendant les premières paroles
publiques de leurs leaders depuis trois
ans la matinée cette foule immense
attend sous un soleil de plomb
la violence va malheureusement entaché
cette journée historique
une centaine de jeunes noirs s'en
prennent à la police j'ai bouteille
pillages de magasins riposte des forces
de l'ordre résultat un morts une
centaine de blessés
la lutte contre l'apartheid et pour la
libération de mandela a été un déclic
pour vous oui c'est ce qui m'a fait
m'engager parce que nous étions nombreux
quand même parmi la jeunesse a refusé ce
régime raciste mais le fait qu'on soit
chacun dans son coin à dire stop à
l'apartheid ne faisait pas avancer les
choses en revanche en s'unissant en se
mettant ensemble en organisant des
manifestations
eh bien nous étions plus forts et on
faisait connaître ce régime raciste
insupportable c'est ça qui m'a poussé à
m'engager à adhérer au parti communiste
à la jeunesse communiste pour pouvoir
avec d'autres mener des combats est de
rendre visible ça m'a formé ce que
j'adore dans nelson mandela c'est pour
ça que pour moi c'est vraiment la
personnalité à retenir dans ce 20ème
siècle le siècle le passé ce que j'adore
chez lui c'est que il a été président de
la république ensuite après sa
libération il a tout fait pour
construire une nation
à réconcilier les noirs et les blancs
ensemble pour faire nation
ensemble il n'a pas été dans la
vengeance
contre les blancs qui ont dirigé le pays
et qui ont été très durs et c'est cette
volonté de réconciliation qu'il a porté
avec monseigneur desmond toutou qui est
décédé récemment qui m'a profondément
marqué parce que c'était pas gagné c'est
très bien expliqué dans le film invictus
d'ailleurs et voilà c'est ce que je
retiens surtout de nelson mandela que je
veux retenir comme le sont la
réconciliation nationale la rubrique
suivante nous ramène à l'histoire
chaotique du communisme
vous avez 20 ans lorsque tombe le mur de
berlin qui remporte avec lui le système
soviétique et fait souffler un grand
vent de liberté à berlin prague bucarest
ou varsovie
le candidat de sondernach fait deux ou
trois meetings par jour alors dans les
coins les plus reculés de sa
circonscription sur des estrades
improvisé il s'efforce d'abord de lutter
contre l'abstention et tente ensuite de
persuader ses auditeurs que le chemin
vers la démocratie est hiver mais qu'il
faut rester vigilant dès la tombée du
mur c'est une étrange un ouvrier est
allemand pas son marteau à celui de
l'ouest pour la première fois l'ouest et
l'est travailler ensemble
et on finit par oublier on finit par
oublier que la derrière il y a encore
des miradors déjà policiers et ses
vocaux qui pendant des années ont fait
peur et qui ont tué oui aujourd'hui la
vie a fini par triompher du murat vers
la
[Musique]
proposition suivie
ou après le mur de berlin c'est
aujourd'hui au rideau de fer que
s'attaquent les allemands de l'est à
seltz d'or au nord de l'allemagne les
gardes-frontières s'acharne à coups de
cisailles contre un dispositif meurtrier
fils de fer barbelés électrifiés et
systèmes de mitraillages à déclenchement
automatique
[Applaudissements]
la nouvelle de la démission des
principaux dirigeants du parti
communiste tchèque tombe comme une bombe
au milieu de la tempérance du forum
civique alexandre do check et vaclav
havel vont lever leur verre à la
tchécoslovaquie libre
et eu ce depuis coupé en deux place de
la république devant le siège du parti
communiste roumain aux balcons des
orateurs prennent la parole à tour de
rôle ils disent représenter un nouveau
parti d'opposition le parti démocrate
[Applaudissements]
on peut parler d'un communiste enlever
la liberté véritable
est ce que tout cela n'a pas quelque peu
ébranlé vos convictions communistes
fabien roussel
non parce que j'ai pas d'airé aux
particules liste français en référence à
ce qui se passait là bas
est d'ailleurs en france je reconnais
pas le courage qui ont adhéré en
référence à ce qui se passait là bas
c'était pas notre idéal communiste quand
même
staline n'a jamais été notre idéal
communiste alors même nom mais à qui
vous ont précédés au malawi mais vous me
posez la question à moi je suis d'une
génération qui n'a pas grandi dans ce
monde là quand même moi j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste français en référence à
la lutte contre l'apartheid et j'ai
ensuite poursuivi mon engagement par
rapport à des combats que nous avons
menés en france pour la défense de
l'industrie du monde du travail pour la
défense
du monde ouvrier c'était ça mon combat
mais le parti communiste français aussi
a été dans la même période le parti qui
s'est battu contre les guerres
coloniales
contre pour l'indépendance de l'algérie
contre la guerre au vietnam
enfin je veux dire on a été aussi ce
parti est bien seule et bien aussi
parfois le seul à mener ces combats pour
la paix contre les colonies
contre toutes ses formes d'impérialisme
qui existait des deux côtés des deux
blocs américains et soviétiques et ça
fait partie de notre histoire notre
histoire à la tout sépare de lumière etc
par aussi dhombres nous les assumons je
les assume c'est pas le cas de tous les
partis y en a beaucoup qui change des
tic est tous les cinq ans ou tous les
dix ans dès qu'ils ont une affaire au
cul c'est pas notre c'est pas notre cas
nous on assume vous pensez de notre
histoire où porter le même nom depuis un
siècle avait effectivement mais on
croyait que cette période cette époque
était révolue
mais quand vous voyez là la folie
criminelle le mépris de toute vie
humaine de vladimir poutine pur produit
du système stalinien vous ne pensez pas
qu'il incarne une forme de continuité
avec le soviétisme non vous rigolez ou
quoi non non mais c'est un libéral c'est
un mec de droite pourquoi vous dites pas
que c'est un dirigeant de droite
libérale qui a vendu tout ce qui était
justement publique d'état il a cassé
justement une économie qui était certes
diriger mais lui il a tout privatiser
c'est lui qui a créé des oligarques qui
aujourd'hui achète des villas et des
yachts que l'on voit sur la côte d'azur
c'est un gars de droite qui flirte avec
l'extrême droite et qui a réagi de
l'union soviétique mais mais il a la
nostalgie des z'arts
c'est ça sa référence c'est l'histoire
de ce peuple aussi mais rien s'est il a
construit un système aujourd'hui ultra
libérale nationaliste il se comporte
comme un dictateur il a appauvri le
peuple russe et d'ailleurs cette guerre
lui permet de masquer
les terribles effets de son 2e en
direction du peuple russe et la pauvreté
qui grandi là bas
n'allez pas lui mais il est plus proche
de la droite et de l'extrême droite que
des valeurs défendues par le parti
communiste français mais il a plusieurs
fois dit son admiration pour mais
c'était par exemple mais ben donc
regarder auprès de qui fait référence un
autre dictateur qui a du sang sur les
mains lui et donc et que nous ne
supportons pas donc
justement il y là il n'a rien à voir
avec nous c'est quand même c'est quand
même gonflé allez plutôt demander à ceux
qui se mettent en photos sur des tracts
avec lui
c'est plutôt ça sait référence vous me
verrez jamais mettre des photos
de poutine dans mes tracts en saluant
son engagement
ça c'est pas le genre de la maison
séquence suivante
zéro pointé pour un un petit écart de
langage pour ses affiches de campagne
que charb vous avez dessiné ces données
il capte en 2004 à lille
un poing levé sur son usine avec un
message sans équivoque c'est le cri de
colère qu'a voulu porter ce jeune
candidat aux cantonales à lille pour
réveiller une campagne somnolente et
remobiliser sur les luttes sociales on
s'adresse donc aux gens aux salariés qui
sont jetés comme des cons comme des
kleenex avoir été utilisé on s'adresse
on l'abat fort boucle là
à l'establishment quoi aux institutions
qui servent à rien mais non mais
regardez le chiffre qu'il y a écrit au
dessus dix mille licenciement en un an
et rappelez-vous ce que l'on avait vu au
début de l'émission ce mineur et ses
reportages qui parlait de 50000
licenciement ça c'est en 2004 donc
quelques décennies après ça continuer
notre région a été d industrialiser
totalement on est au début des années
2000 et c'est à l'époque où les cols
blancs la droite théorise une france
sans usines une france sans usines alors
oui oui j'ai fait cette affiche coup de
gueule coup de colère grossière c'est
pas bien je les dis voilà pas bien voilà
vous pouvez taper sur les doigts c'est
pas bien mais c'était ce cri de colère
que j'avais besoin de porter et j'ai pas
fait que cette affiche bien sûr il y en
avait d'autres avec des propositions
pour mettre un coup d'arrêt à ces
délocalisations pourrait
réindustrialiser notre pays mais c'était
pour vous dire comment comment on
souffre et comment on a souffert de ça
et donc c'était une manière de dire oui
voter communiste au moins pour ça pour
dire stop pour nous donner de la force
pour faire entendre la voix du monde du
travail alors on va prendre de la
hauteur avec un personnage historique
très présent dans cette campagne
invoquer ou revendiquées par presque
tous même par vous avec vos références
au conseil national de là résistance
c'est la rubrique face à de gaulle
nous sommes en 65 entre les deux tours
de l'élection présidentielle le général
évoque le l'europe future
rien n'est plus logique
si tenté que la logique conduisent le
monde
rien n'est plus logique aujourd'hui que
de constituer un marché commun européen
il y à des pays qui sont voisins entre
eux la france l'allemagne l'italie la
hollande la belgique le luxembourg un
jour probablement lors de terre un jour
aussi
l'espagne peut être d'autres voilà un
fait géographique qui est devenu aussi
un fait économique
parce qu'ils sont très rapprochés
parce que ils sont en contact immédiat
direct les uns avec les autres et puis
parce qu'ils sont du même ordre
économique
les uns et les autres ils sont aux
médias
dans leur ensemble parce que jamais
c'est l'heure enfin général de gaulle
c'est qu'il ya pas de langue de bois
aujourd'hui il parle clair la
concurrence est nécessaire c'est
l'aiguillon qui est indispensable au
progrès et notamment progrès app à bloc
de bois qui serait absurde la
concurrence on l'a payé cher
comme on le faisait autrefois comme nous
le faisions autrefois dans des douanes
il avait barrières
et que par conséquent pour se mettre à
la page jour après jour année après
année il faut encore une fois la toque
blanche
bref il faut un marché est tendu voilà
on n'était pas d'accord là la
concurrence moteur du progrès économique
a baissé pour ça je fais ce que j'aime
bien chez le général de gaulle ce qu'il
faut lui reconnaître c'est son parler
franc et clair on a besoin de sens
politique moi je les reconnais ça je
suis pas d'accord avec les propos qu'il
tient je sais pas s'il tiendrait les
mêmes aujourd'hui mais on peut pas le
faire parler vous auriez pu passer
d'autres extraits moi je j'ai aussi le
général de gaulle qui dit en conférence
de presse l'europe l'europe l'europe il
disait la politique de la france ne se
fait pas à la corbeille et il dénoncé la
spéculation l'amour ces compagnies donc
où il veut pour cela on chercherait un
peu en opposition parce qu'il ya ya 100
ans de gaulle différents mais voilà on
peut tout faire dire au général de
gaulle c'est bien pour ça qu'il est
extraordinaire c'est que chacun peut
faire référence à lui en tout cas nous
nous avons été constants sur cette
question de l'union européenne une union
européenne une europe qui se construit
avec les peuples en référence pour
toujours les tirer vers le haut pour
toujours aller mieux pour toujours avoir
plus de travail oui mais l'europe qu'ils
nous ont construit c'est une europe de
la concurrence comme il vient de le dire
et c'est celle qui a déshabillé notre
industrie et qui nous qui nous a
tellement affaiblie et donc elle est à
reconstruire cette europe sur d'autres
bases beaucoup plus humaine et
fraternelle entre les peuples une
madeleine à présent
avec un poète et compagnon de route du
pcf qui figure en bonne place dans votre
panthéon paul eluard la voix de paul
eluard en 58 sur son poème liberté
liberté
jg d'écoliers sur mon pupitre et les
arbres sur le sable sur la neige
j'écris ton nom de l'epr sur toutes les
pages lues sur toutes les pages blanches
pierre sans papiers aux cendres
j'écris ton nom
sur les images torre sur les armes des
guerriers sur la couronne des rois
j'écris ton nom
liberté dont fernand léger fait une
tapisserie qui figurent tous près de
votre bureau c'est ce que j'allais dire
chaque fois que je vais place du colonel
fabien à mon bureau c'est cette belle
tapisserie originale qui figure avec ce
poème entièrement écrits sur 3 mètres de
long et est sur un dessin réalisé par
fernand léger et j'invite d'ailleurs les
téléspectateurs allaient au musée qui
est tenu par sa petite fille d'ailleurs
et on retrouve tout son travail et il y
a un lien très fort entre le parti
communiste français et le monde des arts
de la culture les artistes nous avons
d'ailleurs fait une une exposition
incroyablement belle avec tous ces
artistes qui de près ou de loin ont
dessiné contribué à au grand combat
émancipateur au grand combat pour la
paix pour la fraternité entre les hommes
et les femmes parmi eux il y avait paul
eluard mais il y avait picasso forcément
marcel duchamp
rancillac qui est décédé il n'ya pas
longtemps
c'était voilà cesser les liens que nous
avons avec ces artistes avec lesquels on
a pu s'engueuler avec qui on avait des
désaccords mais avec qui aussi on se
retrouvait pour
parce que les combats pour l'être humain
sont nous ont toujours rassemblés mais
j'ai la même question que pour vos amis
vous avez des goûts littéraires en
dehors des artistes communiste a bien
sûr après les goûts et les couleurs ça
ça diffère mais je suis plutôt fan mois
de deux romans policiers de ce thriller
donc j'essaye de tout s'entend aussi
de de couper quoi ne pas faire que de la
politique restez humains aussi une
archive présidentielle à présent que
nous présentons à tous les candidats
celle de l' alerte verte
en 74 un candidat fait sensation avec un
simple verre d'eau et vous savez ce qui
va se passer et bientôt bientôt manquer
de l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois
devant vous un verre d'eau précieuse
puisque avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis tôt
bon je m'en souviens pas j'étais un peu
petit
c'était dans les spots de la campagne
officielle rené dumont le premier
candidat écolo qui prêchait assez
largement dans le désert les communistes
ont mis longtemps à se réveiller sur la
question de l'écologie non
écoutez vous savez pour préparer cette
élection présidentielle j'ai ressorti
des archives des précédentes élections
présidentielles où nous avions présenté
des candidats et j'ai ressorti un quatre
pages qui avait publié robert hue dans
la campagne de 95
sur l'enjeu environnemental et
écologique et le besoin de sortir d'un
système économique qui
épuise autant les hommes que la planète
et nos ressources naturelles nous avions
à l'époque mis l'accent sur le besoin de
développer les réseaux ferrés le
transport des marchandises de lutter
contre la pollution de l'air le
réchauffement climatique c'était écrit
noir sur blanc et donc
c'était il ya plus de 20 ans et donc
nous portions déjà l'exigence de changer
de système économique et des logiques de
profit qui épuise la planète et les
hommes parce que vous savez le
capitalisme vert que défend certains
écologistes ça ne marche pas le problème
c'est pas la couleur c'est le
capitalisme et nous c'est à ça qu'on
s'attaque pour finir une rencontre
[Musique]
rencontre que nous voulions susciter
entre le candidat des jours heureux vous
même et un grand intellectuel qui était
aussi un grand pessimiste
l'anthropologue claude lévi strauss je
ne cacherai pas que j'ai un tempérament
pessimiste je ne cacherai pas que je ne
me sens pas pleinement heureux dans le
siècle où le hasard ma fenêtre je ne
cacherai pas que j'ai de très grande
inquiétude sur le futur de l'humanité
si elle continue à se laisser à cette
incroyable
prolifération qui ne laissera plus je
n'irai pas à nous mêmes et en tout cas
nos petits-enfants ou arrière petits
enfants si ça continue à ce rythme qu'un
mètre carré des espaces pour se tenir
sur notre terre qui n'est pas
indéfiniment extensible mais ce
pessimisme me paraît être après tout
offrir à l'optimisme sa meilleure chance
parce que c'est à la condition d'être
très pessimiste que nous prendrons
conscience des dangers qui nous menacent
c'est à la condition d'être très
pessimiste que nous aurons le courage
d'adopter les solutions nécessaires et
que donc peut-être nous pourrons
recommencer à avoir une certaine dose
d'optimisme disons modéré le pessimisme
comme levier d'action qu'en pensez vous
fabien roussel je suis par nature
optimiste
parce que la déprime nourrit la déprime
et l'espoir nourri d'espoir et je veux
moi nourrir l'espoir mais lévi-strauss
fait partie justement des lectures que
j'ai eu et pour moi c'est un grand homme
et je comprends je partage ce qu'il dit
dans le sens où
au lendemain de la guerre la seconde
guerre mondiale avec ses millions de
morts et sept choix
qui a ébranlé le monde il a fait partie
de ces grands intellectuels qui ont mis
au coeur du débat l'idée que
la notion de race devait être éliminé de
notre discours et qu'il y avait qu'une
seule race c'était l'être humain le
genre humain il a fait partie de ceux là
et ça ça fait partie des textes qui
m'ont construit et qui ont construit mon
combat contre le racisme et contre
l'antisémitisme
et je sais que parmi ces intellectuels
au lendemain de la guerre au lendemain
de ces crimes atroces industriel qu'il y
a eu contre les juifs les tziganes et et
bien et je comprends qu'ils aient été
ébranlée et pessimiste sur l'avenir de
l'humanité mais ils nous ont fait
progresser aussi au terme de cet adn et
de ce voyage dans les archives de l'ina
y aurait-il fabien roussel un morceau
essentiel de votre adn que nous avons
manqué
à part les romans policiers
non non non non non
je vous avais effectivement en partant
du nord et de ce mineur qui m'a touché
au début
marc est effectivement ce qui m'a
construit ce monde du travail peut-être
si la résistance parce qu'on l'a eue
avec pierre georget le colonel fabien
non c'est vraiment ça qui m'a construit
et vous avez fait une remarquable et
missions des archives qui nous a fait
revisiter l'histoire de notre pays merci
à vous merci avoue fabien roussel
[Musique]